upset and put up their own candidate
that ensures so I don't think there's
any there's no concerted plan to get rid
of her but there is a desire everything
that we're about to see in this press
conference will be designed to calm
those nerves but it matters what voters
think and what uh the markets think as
well as what Tory MPS think everybody is
watching this trust right now it's got
to be an incredible performance on a
personal and a political level can she
pull that off there must be some Furious
Tory party members as well who voted for
Liz truss on that Manifesto big tax cuts
and and growth for the economy and the
like who are now about to see another
U-turn a second U-turn
um there must be a a fury in the shires
about that isn't that
I think that the fury stands to the fact
that every conservative would want to
see lower taxes but what this trust has
done is effectively toxify the entire
idea of lowering taxes because she's
done it in such a way that crashes the
market without due regard to sound money
the other great bit of Tory uh of Tory
of the conservative reputation of the
Bedrock and conservative principles
Liz truss
consciously uh kind of modeled herself
on Margaret Thatcher but in doing so she
modeled herself on she cherry-picked
some bits of the former prime minister's
reputation ideology and policy platform
but not others and I think what what
quite a lot of the conservative would
say is you can't you can't have the tax
cuts without the sound money you've got
there's no shortcut here there's no easy
answer there's no just telling everybody
that we can't go along with orthodoxies
the one is required for the other this
is why this press conference is so
important because you've got to I think
the nation the world is the financial
world is looking this trust in the eye
and going have you genuinely changed how
you see the world and how you're going
to behave now uh and retreated on some
of what what story MPS think it's just
downright mad
um or do you seek to just sort of push
off a bit of the blame not really you
turn on enough of your mini budget
um actually think that your job today is
all about hanging on in the face of
political pressure uh and prevent and
sacrificing crossy glassing as a
sacrificial lamb as a scapegoat in order
to sort of uh try and protect your own
uh your own reputation uh bringing in a
kind of a former foreign secretary to
sort of look credible but without really
going doing the hard yards of policy
work uh to to deliver what's necessary
it you know this press conference is a
credibility test and you'll be able to
hear it from the way she addresses
questions you'll be able to hear it from
the questions themselves I think
um it's one of those 360 job interviews
she's about to go through I wouldn't
expect it to be particularly Pleasant at
a point I'm really interested even to
see just how many questions uh she takes
just how much she's willing to throw
open that there'll be some Contrition
but he's on the big things there'll be
some apology but it is on the
substantial things how much does he try
and just sort of go it was him and he's
gone and how much do people believe that
so those are the really really important
questions that we're gonna we're gonna
find out and it requires huge
flexibility to deal with that sort of
you know the the slightly raw knuckle
you know hostile questions at A Moment
Like This and she's not like Boris
Johnson she hasn't spent a long she
hasn't thrown herself open to the media
she's not one of those Prime Ministers
who's done sort of
um uh press confrontation I'm going to
interrupt Sam about because she's about
to speak let's listen into the prime
minister is Trust
good afternoon
my conviction that this country needs to
go for growth is rooted in my personal
experience
I know what it's like to grow up
somewhere that isn't feeling the
benefits of growth
I saw what that meant
and I'm not prepared to accept that for
our country
I want a country where people can get
good jobs new businesses can set up and
families can afford an even better life
that's why from day one I've been
ambitious for growth
since the 2008 financial crisis the
potential of this great country has been
held back by persistently weak growth
I want to deliver a low tax high-wage
high growth economy
is what I was elected by my party to do
that mission remains
people across this country rightly want
stability
that's why we acted to support
businesses and households with their
energy costs this winter
it's also the case that global economic
conditions are worsening due to the
continuation of Putin's appalling war in
Ukraine
and on top of this debt was amassed
helping people through the covered
pandemic
but it is clear that parts of our mini
budget went further and faster the
markets were expecting
so the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change
we need to act now to reassure the
markets of our fiscal discipline
I have therefore decided to keep the
increase in corporation tax that was
planned by the previous government
this will raise 18 billion pounds per
year
it will act as a down payment on our
full medium-term fiscal plan which will
be accompanied by a forecast from the
Independent obr
we will do whatever is necessary to
ensure debt is falling as a share of the
economy in the medium term
we will control the size of the state to
ensure that taxpayers money is always
well spent
our public sector will become more
efficient to deliver world-class
services for the British people
and spending will grow less rapidly than
previously planned
I met the former Chancellor earlier
today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend
and he shares my vision to set this
country on the path to Grace
today
I have asked Jeremy Hunt to become the
new Chancellor
he's one of the most experienced and
widely respected government ministers
and parliamentarians and he shares my
convictions and Ambitions for our
country
he will deliver the medium-term fiscal
plan at the end of this month
he will see through the support we are
providing to help families and
businesses including our energy price
guarantee that's protecting people from
higher energy bills this winter
and he will drive our mission to go for
growth including taking forward the
supply side reforms that our country
needs
we owe it to the next Generation to
improve our economic performance
to deliver higher wages new jobs and
better public services and to ease the
burden of debt
I have acted decisively today because my
priority is ensuring our country's
economic stability
as prime minister I will always act in
the National interest
this is always my first consideration
I want to be honest this is difficult
but we will get through this storm and
we will deliver the strong and sustained
growth that can transform the prosperity
of our country for generations to come
I'll now take questions
can I start with Ben Reilly Smith
Telegraph
thank you prime minister clearly a
difficult day can you explain to the
public why you think you should remain
as prime minister given you've jumped to
keep tax cuts that led you to be elected
and got rid of your Chancellor
I'm absolutely determined to see through
what I've promised to deliver a higher
growth more prosperous United Kingdom to
see us through the storm we Face we've
already delivered the energy price
guarantee making sure people aren't
facing huge bills this winter
but it was right in the face of the
issues that we had
that I acted decisively to ensure that
we have economic stability because that
is vitally important to people and
businesses right across our country
uh
just Harry Cole
thank you Professor Harry got from the
Sun you're the one that wanted to cut
the 45p rate you stood on the platform
to win the leadership of the
conservative party on a platform to cut
corporation tax you and the chancellor
the ex-chancellor designed this budget
together in lockstep we're told at times
in Secrets the two of you he has to go
because of the Fallout from it how come
you get to stay
well my priority is making sure we
deliver the economic stability that our
country needs that's why I had to take
the difficult decisions I've taken today
the mission Remains the Same we do need
to raise our country's economic growth
levels we do need to deliver for people
across the country we're committed to
delivering on the energy price guarantee
which people are already seeing in their
bills but ultimately we also need to
make sure that we have economic
stability and I have to act in the
National interest as prime minister
um
Chris Mason BBC
excuse the bluntness Prime Minister but
given everything that has happened what
credibility do you have to continue
governing
what I've done today
is made sure that we have economic
stability in this country
Jeremy Hunters Chancellor is somebody
who shares my desire for a high growth
low tax economy but we recognize because
of current market issues we have to
deliver the mission in a different way
and that's what we are absolutely
committed to do achieving that stability
and what is a very difficult time
globally
uh
uh Robert peston
prime minister the former Tory
Chancellor Philip Hammond has just said
that you have totally trashed the Tory
parties election winning reputation for
economic competence will you apologize
to your party
well I am determined to deliver on what
I set out when I campaigned to be party
leader we need to have a high growth
economy but we have to recognize that we
are facing very difficult issues as a
country and it was right in the National
interest that I made the decisions I've
made today to restore that economic
stability so we can deliver first of all
helping people through this winter and
next winter with our energy bills but
also making sure that our country is on
the long-term footing for sustainable
economic growth thank you very much
everybody
are you prime minister
the Prime Minister Liz trust perhaps not
speaking for as long as many had
expected and certainly not taking as
many questions as many broadcasters and
journalists had hoped that she said that
she still believes in growth since day
one I've been ambitious for growth and
that mission remains but she did say
parts of the mini budget went further
and faster than the markets could deal
with and as a result she carried out
that U-turn on corporation tax saying it
will bring in 18 billion pounds now she
spoke about quasi-guating and she said
I'm sorry to lose the former Chancellor
but Jeremy Hunt the new Chancellor as we
know shares my convictions and Ambitions
for this country and then she said it
again and in fact she said it numerous
times we'll ask Sam in a moment if he
was keeping a count how many times did
you hear her say we are going to restore
economic stability she was asked what
credibility do you still have as as
prime minister having carried out this
u-turn at quasi-quarting gets to stay
she was asked how come you get to stay
and she said that she will deliver this
mission of hers in a different way
fascinating you said earlier Sam didn't
you that it's all about the presentation
it's as much about how she delivers that
speech as it is about the content what
was your reaction to it
I mean it's very hard to watch that and
not feel slightly tense but because you
did not get the impression of a prime
minister
completely at ease with the situation
and you're right you ran through the
summary of what she said
um before the press conference much much
much shorter than I expected she only
spoke for seven minutes into four
questions five questions
um when she did so I was looking for
certain things to what extent did she
accept the blame for what's happened in
order to tell the markets the voters and
her MPS she would do things differently
in future and the other side is almost
numb
she argues the reason things have gone
wrong was because of Market reaction
that's not a mayor culpr that's not
saying any bit of my vision is wrong
that's simply saying that there was an
external reason that meant that that
things got a bit hairy we'll put that
right she did not resign from the
decisions that she made she sought to
blame somebody else in fact she pretty
much started her statement by saying she
was right about everything
right that's quite incredible she thinks
she was right about her Mission which is
to uh Kickstart growth she said there
hadn't really been great since 2008 I
mean that that's that that sort of
broadly treats me conservative
government it's all conservative Downing
Street for you know 12 of the last 14
years since 2008 so that's quite a
Punchy statement by any by any standards
but what she was not doing was saying uh
she sort of conceded she went to too far
too fast but not that she did the wrong
thing not that she understands the
principles of sound money and then under
politics this I felt was absolutely
fascinating she has sacked quesy
Crossing today
and she did not assign any blame to him
he didn't say it was his fault he didn't
say he got he got it wrong I mean on one
level we were talking about this earlier
you can't because it was her as well she
got inside of all the policies but at
the same point perhaps perhaps she
doesn't dare I mean perhaps she's
worried about what he might say in a day
or a week and the comments are on telly
you know I sacked him but I'm not going
to tell you why and what an
extraordinary position uh that's it
instead you've got a knight in shining
armor Jeremy Hunt he's going to come
along on his Steed Dismount outside
number 11 walk in and deal with economic
stability
yes but the I I think the argument from
some Tory MPS would be how do you get to
economic stability unless you can
realize recognize address and undo the
problems that have got us to this point
and then one one final thought
she reversed almost nothing of the mini
budget yes she reversed the corporation
tax rise one of the two big Promises of
her election campaign but I did unless
I'm missing something I didn't hit
anything else
because she spent hundreds of billions
of pounds in that mini budget and she's
now reversed a second bit but there's
vast ways the thing that the thing that
under the thing that the city was quite
spooked about was the sheer scale of the
universal energy price help right every
company every household two years for
the for the for the consumer stuff you
know she doubled down on that that's the
thing that's astronomically expensive
that uh that um that basically are
really upset uh people who watch boring
levels and want Britain to live within
their means whether you're on the market
side of the political side so in
substance not very much of a mayor culpa
um
but he was just so awkward to watch I
mean you were not you were not sensing a
prime minister injury of course you're
not going to enjoy a day like today but
it's not your job to Telegraph your lack
of enjoyment it's your job to show that
you are in control you have a plan and
you will sort this out and and viewers
will judge the extent to which that they
you they think that she did that
um but is this plan big enough is this
bold enough is this the reset that
conservative is looking at is this the
change of direction that the markets
need is this uh a performance that will
be seen as credible in the eyes of
Voters those are the three verdicts that
we wait for after an extraordinarily
short not particularly enthusiastic
press conference yeah it's going to be
it's going to be fascinating isn't it to
to get that reaction and that and that
reaction will be coming thick and fast
I'm sure but as you say it was so short
wasn't it and and it leaves many
questions unanswered and that's the
problem here isn't it because if you're
the if you're the captain of the ship
and you're steering that ship in a New
Direction people want to know exactly
where they're going here's one question
in neon lights uh Liz truss in that
press conference said spending will grow
less rapidly so are we now heading into
a path of spending cuts in lots of
different bits the economy might not be
overall spending reductions uh but it
sounds like we are now heading into a
very difficult uh situ situation when it
comes to Pub bits of Whitehall Public
spending this trust of course has spent
hundreds of billions of pounds on an
energy price freeze and all the rest of
it so she's not going to cut overall
public spending but she's now signaling
to everybody that she is going to cut
Whitehall budget so whether that's a
squeeze on schools or police you know
which could impact Frontline numbers or
uh quite how they're going to deal with
the energy all of these things all of
these things are going to come to
enormous pressure between now and the
31st of October a date which remained
the moment where the obr will the
independent fiscal Watchdog will tell us
how big the the um the black hole is
that she needs to find it's going to be
filled a bit with corporation tax we
learned that today 80 billion pounds a
year didn't hear anything else
so do those three audiences find it
credible we're going to bring you that
information all afternoon well let's
find out right now Sam thank you for the
moment our business presenter Ian King
is in the city he was listening uh to
that news conference along with the rest
of the city and indeed Traders around
the globe Ian what did you make of it
what are the markets making of it
I can tell you what the markets have
made of it uh really it's been very
interesting all morning um guilt yields
which are obviously implied government
borrowing costs have been coming down
for most of the morning us indeed they
have done for most of the last 48 hours
but really uh things started to turn
around the time that quasi quaten's uh
resignation was confirmed you've seen
Gil starting to creep higher uh right
across the yield curve really the 20 to
30 year guilts obviously uh crucially
the ones that the bank of England has
been buying at the moment they have
started to tick back higher again in the
last hour or so and uh the sell-off that
we've seen in Sterling has intensified
as well now there is a theory to this I
mean there is an old saying in markets
that it is better to travel than to
arrive you you buy the uh the rumor and
sell the confirmation you buy the rumor
and sell the fact and there's a bit of
that that's perhaps going on I think the
markets were pricing in quasi-carten's
resignation and crucially this uh
Backtrack on the corporation tax
decision that that is going to now rise
after all I can give you some reaction
from business on this uh Jonathan this
is a statement that's just been put out
by make UK which is the key industry
body for British manufacturers and uh
its chief executive Stephen phippsen has
just said on its own the short-term
decision to increase corporation tax
again sends the wrong signal to
investors as to how attractive the UK is
I say destination for foreign investment
however there are far bigger issues at
play than just a single decision on tax
the UK urgently needs a long-term
credible economic and Industrial
strategy which includes a wide-ranging
view of how we boost investment in the
round this must include a properly
designed and targeted taxation system
which reflects the real world investment
decisions that companies make we cannot
go on zigzagging from one policy to the
next and uh make UK are also they had a
survey on manifest factoring investment
and that one of the key findings in this
two-thirds of the companies in this
survey say increasing the rate of
corporation tax will make the UK less
attractive for foreign investment more
than half of companies say it will
result in manufacturers investing less
capital and a third say an increase will
wipe out the benefits of increased
Capital allowances and I think that is
something that businesses are really
going to be looking for now
um the the last uh sorry the last but uh
two chancellors now uh Rishi soon at
Clear defeated conservative leadership
Contender of course now in his budget in
the spring uh he was the guy who of
course announced this big increase in
corporation tax from 19 to 25 but in
doing so he sweetened the Pill by adding
investment allowances and release that
were all aimed at encouraging businesses
to invest and obviously that's to try
and get to grits with the UK's very long
established productivity issues and uh
really uh quasi-karting went for the
opposite approach of just going for a
very very low a corporation tax rate I
think businesses will now be looking for
Jeremy Hunt the new Chancellor to
reintroduce some of these uh investment
reliefs and uh and tax release to
encourage investment further there is
also a very specific issue Jonathan with
the banking sector now the banks already
pay a higher rate of Taxation there is a
surcharge on Bank profits and uh that
was uh going to remain in place when
corporation tax uh uh was uh the
increases weren't going to go ahead now
that increase is going to go ahead I
suspect the banking sector in particular
will be looking for some sort of
remedial action to bring down the
banking surcharge so they aren't left
paying a higher than expected rate of
tax one other point to make is that this
higher rate of income tax for corporates
means that uh effectively the UK now has
one of the highest corporation tax in
the developed world if you look at
corporation tax as a proportion of GDP
only Australia and Japan will be higher
and again that is not a message that the
government really wants to be sending
out to the world right now
okay Ian I know you're going to keep an
eye on things in the city for us we will
speak to you again I'm sure throughout
the afternoon at meanwhile our political
editor Beth rigney is with me now uh the
lady apparently is for turning a massive
climb down Beth you were in that room
she spoke for what six or seven minutes
eight minutes
you were recording it and four or five
questions four questions what did you
make of it look uh in terms of the
policy announcement there you had the
second massive U-turn and if MPS was
saying at Party Conference the 45 Pence
uh scrap in plans to scrap that was not
instrumental in turning changing her
Economic Policy this one is because
she's decided to implement Rishi sunax
plan to lift corporation tax to 25 pence
in April next year
so she and she wanted he wanted to lift
it to 25 Pence she said when she was
running to be leader I'm going to not
introduce that and I want to cut it to
19 pencil keep it at 19 Pence that was a
major platform which she was elected as
territory leader on she has now u-tanned
on that and she's done it it's a sizable
policy change it's 18 billion pounds
worth of tax cuts reversed so that's
point one Jonathan that is hugely
significant she's also sacked her
Chancellor saying that that she was
sorry to see him go even though she was
the one that asked him to stand down so
in terms of the Liz trust government
admission she is now saying that she's
ripping up a big part of that mini
budget and that campaign platform that
she stood on and yet she didn't really
want to ask questions and I have to say
that the journalists in the room we were
genuinely shocked that she only took
four questions she took uh four
questions one from the telegraph one
from the son one from the BBC and one
from ITV and then left the room so the
Jonas in the room were we that this is
such a big announcement does that send
because that in itself doesn't sound
good the reason the reason why this
matters is not just the communication
with the public on a decision to reverse
a massive part of that mini budget and
Sack her Chancellor just weeks into her
Premiership and my messages from
conservative MPS ahead of that press
conference well she has to put in a
really good reassuring performance in
order to reassure them that she is not
politically out of her depth that she
can handle being the Prime Minister and
what she did and now I don't think
reassured anyone now in fact one MP
messaged me afterwards and said even for
Liz trust that was shockingly bad that's
what an MP messaged me now what was she
doing in terms of the markets there were
two other things in there she said that
the 18 billion pounds of tax cut
reversals she said said was a down
payment on our medium Town fiscal plan
what might she mean by that she's
signaling to the markets that she's
prepared to make more reversals on the
policy in order to reassure the markets
so that's an important message that she
gave to the market she gave a second
Mark message to the markets Jonathan as
well she said that spending will not
grow as fast as previously planned now
whether that is spending cuts or how she
actually does that in practice but she's
signaling to the markets as well that
she recognizes that 60 billion pound
black hole in the books which the ifs
was talking about and she's looking at
ways to deal with that but I do not
think that that will have reassured
politicians and MPS she is in deep
trouble you're not convinced it was
enough well we shall find out to help me
in coming hours and days Beth for the
moment thank you very much you're
watching Sky News where the Prime
Minister has said she still believes in
growth she says that from day one I've
been ambitious for growth that mission
remains but she has carried out a huge
U-turn over corporation tax something
which she says will bring in 18 billion
pounds she has also sacked Chancellor
quasi quateng and she has appointed
Jeremy Hunt will have ongoing coverage
throughout the day here on Sky News
statements
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign